police in north las vegas are looking
for a driver who left a man dead in a
road happened near simmons in alexander
around 3 o'clock this morning jeremy j
ford tells us what we know so far about
the investigation in the victim
the incident took place here where a
young man in front of his house was
fatally struck by a passing car and
residents tell me that cars usually
speed down this block
someone got hit
and someone came flying through and then
they hit him then that's
basically all that went down resident bo
jordan says he never thought something
like this would happen to someone he
knew i see when news someone gets it i'm
like wow that's unfortunate but having
it happen to someone so close to you
it's like it hits a different part of
your heart a personal friend of the
deceased he says something needs to be
done about speeding throughout
residential areas because usually
because then just
like such a straight path people use it
as like a straightaway just fly just so
they can see how fast that car goes for
a few times therefore putting innocent
lives in danger i see when new someone
gets it i'm like wow that's unfortunate
but having it happen to someone so close
to you it's like it hits a different
part of your heart
causing accidents and leaving family
members behind to bear the burden just
be careful and be safer with what you do
because it could be someone close to you
next and i wouldn't want to wish that on
anybody with these words of advice to
the perpetrator honestly
from what had happened
just turn yourself in for it because
there's no like i don't know i don't
really have any bad words it's just what
goes wrong comes around and it's going
to happen sooner or later
the residents in this neighborhood are
now asking anyone who may have seen
something or have camera footage to
please report it to the police
jeremy j ford live local now